say that we're given just this point
here
it's pretty weird but if you have a
function that tells you how far away the
nearest surface is
without telling you anything else at all
that's actually all that's needed to
build entire complex 3d worlds entirely
out of math
the technique is called ray marching and
it relies entirely on having a sine
distance function of the scene and sine
distance functions aren't too hard to
understand
if i have two points here let's just
make some points appear
and we want the distance between them
the distance is defined by the length of
p2 minus p1
so now if this were the distance between
say a point in a circle instead
we can model this with length e2 minus
p1 minus r
which you might realize gives you
positive values outside of the circle
and negative values inside of it hence
the sign part of the name so let's take
our world and visualize it as a distance
field
so for any given point in the world here
we can use our magic sign distance
function and that will tell us how far
away the nearest surface is
now it doesn't tell us anything about
where it is but weirdly enough that
doesn't actually matter
to render this distance field you need
to walk through it
so if i've got our eye up here let's say
that we want to get the pixel color in
this direction
so we know from the distance field
function the closest surface to the eye
is this far away now we don't actually
know where it is but that doesn't matter
we know we can travel at least this
distance safely along our view vector
then you do the same thing at the new
point
you sample the distance function
figure out how far away things are
that gives you a safe distance to travel
and then you can repeat that process
over and over again until you feel like
you're close enough to the surface of an
object
extending this to 3d is pretty much
exactly the same thing
and that's where you can really start to
do weird and cool stuff things that are
super hard to do with normal techniques
but before we do that let's take a step
back
the scene ideally looks like this but in
reality looks more like this
because we haven't got any lighting we
can assign color based on depth which is
basically distance fog
and that'll give us a start
but to light we need normals
now normals are actually quite simple to
generate off of distance fields
at any given surface point you take a
couple extra samples of the distance
field near the point
compute the differences along each axis
and you've got a normal it's really that
simple
having normals gives you access to doing
basic lighting to get shadows you simply
ray march towards any lights
recording how close you got to any
surfaces
the awesome thing here being that you
get soft shadows for almost nothing
so now that we know how to light let's
look at how scenes are constructed
you've got your basic spheres like we've
seen already but you've also got other
stuff
some very smart people have already
figured out distance functions for a lot
of common shapes
cubes donuts pyramids
and you can even have weird and exotic
shapes
you might be thinking this is a lot of
work to do to do really basic stuff and
that's sort of true actually
but this is where it also starts to get
really interesting because you can
combine and distort things in ways that
you just can't with traditional
techniques
so we have functions for individual
shapes but what's not immediately
obvious is that having multiple shapes
is as simple as taking the min of their
sdf values
so in this case having a box and a
sphere is as simple as taking a min of
the sphere's sdf value and the box's sdf
value
and because combining objects is just
the min of the two values an interesting
property of the min of two functions is
that it can be blended together it can
be smoothed out
look at these two functions here
i've just got a basic line and a
parabola
now if i were to take the min of these
two functions it would look something
like this
so we've got the min of these two
functions
but right where the functions meet
you've got this sharp edge and ideally
we want them to smoothly meet instead
and blend just between
and luckily this is a solved problem
already smooth's maximums exist so a
smooth min is just negative smooth max
negative a negative b and some k
smoothing value so with our 3d objects i
can slowly adjust the smoothing
coefficient here and we've got one just
kind of melting into the other like it's
made of butter or something from here it
just gets wilder because now you can
really start messing with these distance
fields so combining objects is called a
union which is one operation in
constructive solid geometry or csg the
opposite of a union being a subtraction
that's when you subtract one object from
another and with sdfs this is a simple
max of negative a and b the last
operation being an intersection which is
forming an object only where two objects
meet and again super easy that's a max
of a and b
operations to transform objects actually
modify the space itself so we can take
our combined object and apply rotation
scales pretty much similar to the way
you'd expect to do it for normal 3d
objects but more exotic transformations
like bends and twists are possible as
well which i mean yeah you could do that
in a vertex shader so let's see some
stuff that's not possible in a vertex
shader since you're actually
transforming the space itself i can do
weirder stuff like repeat the space
creating multiple copies of the same
object and this is pretty much for free
in the shader this doesn't stop me from
applying individual transforms rotations
or basically do whatever i want to each
copy as well and we can pretty much do
this in any direction all the way to
infinity which is pretty neat and you
may be surprised to know but pretty much
this entire video was made using shaders
raid marching and sign distance
functions
so they're a pretty versatile and fun
thing to know a bit about if you wanted
to up your shader game check out my glsl
course i cover a lot of the basic
concepts in much more detail otherwise
the code will be up on github until next
time cheers